what drew you to this particular story
yeah I met the seniors in 2008 they had
an open studio day and they live in
DUMBO which is a neighborhood in
Brooklyn where a lot of artists used to
live and now it's sort of changed as a
lot of these artists neighborhoods the
rents are rising and you see uh narco
studio is kind of it's this time warp of
a space I mean it was this place you
could go and it felt like you were
inside this you know truly authentic you
know artist space that sort of was
harken back to the sort of 70s Soho
downtown scene I really kind of colored
my impression of when I thought of you
know cultural would define New York
cultural for me was I moved up to New
York and met him about a year later so I
was quite young when I was introduced to
them and just being in their space it
just everything felt everything was
enticing that the space is beautiful
they're beautiful you know I thought I
could do this kind of intimate visual
portrait of this couple and everything
they do is with so much purpose and
really shows their character visually so
I was starting from this place where I I
knew that it could you know I could
create a real something different and
unique with the mood of the film and
then the the real process was just sort
of our relationship and our how our
relationship developed and and how you
know I was there as narco was sort of
going through this change and just
following them so I didn't necessarily
know it would be a feature-length film
when when I met them I thought it might
be a short and initially it was more
focused on Lucio's art from the
beginning but then it sort of took this
whole new world when it became much more
about their relationship in particularly
narco sort of journey to really you know
step step up and sort of show her work
to the public and enter ushio in a
different way we artists everybody order
artists exhibitionist so you know some
people think the artist lives in a
isolated arrive and hate
to be interviewed or affirmative or
being close to the normal life but it's
a lie
you know every artist wanted to show the
works and every writers wanted their
works published and wanted to recognize
you know only like a sudden gia type
they already famous so that's why he can
make offense and refute the interview
but otherwise we all wanted to be
recognized so we agreed but to actually
it took five years to raise him to raise
duck to build grown up to be to be
artist because in the beginning when he
came he was so tall he is tall so I
thought he was grownups
but to clear he came with his friend
Patrick who started together and I
thought it was Patrick whose idea and
Patrick was making because Patrick was
the Torah and look so handsome and mass
murderer but one day after two years
soon after the beginning a partly
correct because he became busy for him
or his own and he Patrick said oh it's a
dark film that's why he continued and it
was surprising on that kid offer
continue to coming fresh with us with
that particular rate and we artists with
fiber offer so it's like I got to more
often in my orphanage and it took like
two three years until I feel comfortable
with his existence with ours
and that time he's becoming like my
house one of my house fault
like hospital husky in a rice cooker
vacuum cleaner so I I can you know
pyramid do which are to some irritation
but to actually beginning exact google
docs idea I could live with Sherlock one
cross lines to but to the you know our
artists drive our t2 surface one Paris
right
sometimes three or well provides there
were even minors but maybe exactly the
still on the way to understand
everything so he'd walk it's not to
finish their tirado the Missy did not
talk in a shooting in Newark in the
audience and was going to attach to that
you know no standing ovation what kita
to do this oh so that feeling came when
I was at the screening of misery their
words standing ovation by fifteen
hundred people so look you know I know
standing ovation the chakra mardian oh
uh Yankees no unanimity says you go home
now me that we taught to can do now I
know suppose I go got a big Christmas
that I was just just sort honest that
time just like how I felt when I
witnessed Matsui when he was with the
Yankees hit the home run
so today I know working on or painting
to grasscarp shadowboxing painting you
know audience more direct Ronnie and
also you audience new condo at Arianna
sakyo discrete Dana to Nora we're gonna
Cora gotta know projector this so I
would really really like to have that
kind of astonishment to all my audience
with my sculpture and my paintings
directly to the people that see my
painting I mean the the core scenes in
the film are the ones where I was
essentially became invisible I don't
speak Japanese I could understand a
little bit and I had translators for the
interviews there's some voiceover in the
film so those you know I had a
translator there but for a lot of the
scenes I was just sort of observing them
either you know at the dinner table or
on their deck I didn't know what they
were saying but I think it actually
helped me sort of become more invisible
and sort of just be a part of the wall I
mean you know when they weren't so
conscious of me
you know hearken on their every every
word so I think that actually helped and
then also just being being there when I
first started they would ask me every
time I came they would ask you know what
why I was filming and norica would ask
specifically an issue and then at a
certain point they just stopped asking
and I think
Nariko it's at some point you know
because Norco realized that the the
shift of the film was turning more to
her but I think you she I didn't really
realize that in some north and and when
I would come over who she would be
concerned and asking you know when when
Zach gonna film me and Norco would have
to give some excuse to show well
secondly as title only has so much time
today and and he has to go back to work
so he'll shoot you another time you know
who she o is very concerned that he
wasn't getting enough screen time and in
the end was was rather shocked I think
to see the final film because he was
sort of under the impression that was
going to be more about him the Jews were
like I know you know speed about you
know
so he's in the submit an idea then
irrigate all carnage Ernesto you made a
symbol not I don't want Tomas I really
believe that jaws from Spielberg it
really contains all his passion and all
the experience he had before the the
movie and all the dreams that he had no
motive and scat oh I know Booker Ghana
Sierra whoever there to tell you who you
can't stay so even now I really feel
that that was a film by it was really
really a poetry da Carano Iman Iman or
Jordan or Speedwagon agility mojo
continues there are nonsense I coached a
little de agua juice I know justice so I
am I still have that feeling of being
the youthfulness
Spielberg had four jobs so I consider
myself 81 year old jaws the work I did
before qt
I was copying from the past like my
favorite caricatures of Nikki rancheros
so cute is my own creation so until the
cutie I didn't make anything else so
cute is my first one so I don't know my
future if I make different works and
greater than QT or not this is my
destiny
you have to continue it